what's happening reject nation thank you
so much for clicking on this video leave
a like guys uh the door's gonna be a
little bit more open today than usual
just because uh we got some cats and i
want to make sure they'll ride in cause
i hear something you won't even notice
if i leave because it'll be jump cuts
we're gonna watch arcane episode two
today from season one subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
arcane episode is up i want to thank
everyone who joined our patreon page
just from the first episode that means a
hell of a lot to us full-length alongs
where you sync up with the time code for
arcane over there cover a bunch of shows
where the same tier you get the option
for both reaction highlights and or
watch alongs included as well lastly
thank you for the boys over at prepper
for editing these down for us um this is
a last-minute decision and they have
been on top of their game and i really
appreciate it guys let's see what's
going on with episode two that's us
league of legends experts
break it all down for you easter eggs
and theories played the whole thing last
night no you're
all the league of legends
[Music]
hello
is someone in there oh the other side of
the door do a little rock
let's do this
did he die
he's a lie
you never know he could die by the end
of this episode
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god the whole world will forget
peter parker spider-man
what the hell
[Laughter]
[Music]
the music in this show is also so
phenomenal yeah he sent me here to
ensure that anything dangerous is
removed according to my list includes
you
what
how am i dangerous no that's for the
council to decide
oh i believe i've discovered something
truly incredible
a way to harness magic through science
magic yes
no
no
the arcane is dangerous
jace you worried powder's gonna beat you
again hey if she didn't keep fixing
these things i wouldn't keep missing hmm
oh fun oh hell yeah i want it you guys
know i wouldn't take you on a job you
couldn't handle right are you kidding
that was the best job we've ever done
maybe just don't take powder next time
gosh that's a dick
[Music]
oh my god she's actually really skilled
sharp shooter
[Music]
we just need a job that involves a lot
of shooting
i think she just panics too much she
gets in her own way
give me a name
gross
you should see this
holy moly
search them
oh damn this is bad yeah that escalated
except for magic
oh no
wow
why does the show look so awesome such a
cyberpunk vibe yeah we've got the
numbers to beat him yeah let's teach him
what it means to mess with us
he doesn't want war
this will blow over we just need to
stand together the vander i knew the one
who built the underground wouldn't be
afraid to fight
but they don't need a fight
do i look afraid
no
you look weak
oh
vander's
gotta deal with the enforcers
what
do we learned that deal fully before
i know i mean he talked to the the yeah
yeah
i don't know if i don't think we found
out the main particulars of the deal
this [ __ ] looks like a wakanda yeah
that's a good goal it came to nothing
so you're saying your study was
meaningless
it was revolutionary how all i see is a
boy meddling with things he doesn't
understand
the academy seems to have loosened its
standard tilde sweating
[Laughter]
i was trying to create magic
do tell
you don't understand what's at stake
but how can you
that's a burden that only i here carry
oh
time
lays waste to civilizations that cannot
happen here my boy
my son isn't in his right mind oh man
i moved that jaceby summarily expelled
from the academy
and remanded to the care of his parents
all those in favor
[Music]
[Laughter]
first time i've been invited to the
lanes
it better be worth my time oh is he
creating magic he must be yeah
i could have convinced the council
if my own family won't help me
i'll find someone who will
i'll find four kids four children
did his actions lead to the prologue
that we had or the
the bad guys
real power doesn't come to those who
were born strongest or fastest or
smartest it comes to those who will do
anything
to achieve it
that's motivating time to let the
monster out
this guy's a fantastic manipulator
oh
no
with all due respect counselor don't you
think we've pushed them hard enough
whatever it takes turn the other city
upside down if you have to just find
them that's what he wanted to hear
really
yeah let's play dirty sick
he must have a real personal reason
though for why he doesn't like these
guys why didn't i became a foursome he
probably came from here
no i didn't expect that
you can't escape the past right
here's shame if i had to put them on
again
castellans
[Music]
all i need is a spider-man blood drop
oh jesus
and i'm gonna bury the lot of you
is she drunk already
strong stuff
oh my dude
[Music]
am i interrupting
you're about to kill yourself
don't don't let me stop you i was an
outsider the moment i stepped foot and
built over didn't have the benefits of a
patron or a name i simply believed in
myself which is why i'm here the
american way
no one thinks it can be done
when you're going to change the world
don't ask for permission
i don't even know your name
it's victor
that match cut makes it look like
they're linked in some way yeah maybe
what makes you different makes you
strong
always remember that okay
that is the theme of this whole episode
oh no
just giving us holy [ __ ]
wow cool another another really great
episode a little bit more somber not
really as action-packed but you got a
lot more world building here and
expansion on the universe
at hand and i
again i'm really impressed with the way
the catalyst of the situation
seemed like it's kind of a fun little
heist gone wrong
and how it's literally the catapult for
everything that's going on like the guy
who's going to the who's the guy the
blonde dude who
they got into a fight with
oh
yeah and now hulking out
and
it's so cool like with the trial that
you you see
the who the person was on the other side
of the door because i thought i was like
old man scientist that's what i thought
like yeah doc brown or something like
that that's what i was saying oh just
some young young aspiring scientist guy
who has a
fascinating plan
and it is cool how they flesh out the
way
the law and the politics work here
of this wasn't even this guy's fault
what happened and now he's been put on
trial he's been expelled and you've come
to find out what he wants to do is
combine science with magic and it is
neat how they have like this whole
industrial revolution that they've and
the city that they have here and like
the
the great sheen that all this is
but magic has this like terrible
reputation in this awful past
and so my question though is because i'm
a tad confused the the very first
episode the opening
i was under the impression that was one
of those
here's what's going to happen
what we're building up to something
terrible that's to come
but now when i was watching some of
these scenes and hearing about their
parents and stuff i'm like wait a minute
did i totally misinterpret that without
a flashback because i thought when they
were like walking away in the cities
behind them that that was that was uh
something that's terrible to come and i
was like okay so we got two plots here
that are going one with
baddie guy who i don't know who that is
so sinister do with the evil eye and
then his funny scientist and then you
have aspiring scientist character jace
jace you have the inspired scientist
character now teaming up with victor and
it's like okay
is the evil thing and the destruction
and the war and then you got of course
the enforcers and the upper class
wealthy people dealing with the
underworld so it's building up this
chaos
of what's going to come and summon what
feels like an inevitable war so
i thought like okay the the opening
scene when you see vander at that when
he picks them up was like this is what i
was trying to warn everyone about and
try and prevent everything from
happening
right it could absolutely be that i i
feel like the thing that would tell us
is how old they are the kids are in that
flashback yes i don't remember in a full
detail and i don't want to revisit it
too much and try to dissect it yeah yeah
yeah i mean it could be just what uh you
know put them as orphans in vander's
care right but it could also
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if there's
some kind of flash forward like here is
yeah the
what did you take it as i thought it was
a flash forward i thought it was a
flashback
oh really okay yeah i thought it was
just a sort of here's kind of a tonal
chaos moment but the thing is i can see
where you're coming from because it puts
you in those shoes so much
it feels like a present moment you know
um but yeah i think i took it ultimately
as a flashback of like okay you know
this guy rescued them and now they all
live together and you know cut to a few
years later and now they're pulling jobs
yes
um which i mean i love that aspect of it
though i like when when a show will take
something like that because you know
it's like with a group of you know
have they explored the history of what
happened there yet that like led the
world to being this way
of what happened was going on during
that if it is a flashback
no yeah no they haven't explained that
not that i
think i mean
unless they're hinting at it in this
episode where the you know the one guy
says you know like you want to read
we tried that once and it went really
terribly odds are you're right yeah but
it sounds like they haven't tried the
magic thing for for a long long time
yeah yeah it's like i don't know exactly
how that lines up either
um
either way i mean i'm sure we'll uncover
it
even if that's a flash forward or a
flashback whoever which one is right
everything else i'm saying i still think
is very true is that like all these
puzzle pieces you're like where's
where's the real crumble of all this
system going to happen yeah and whether
flash back or forward i think it does
just highlight you know a
the sort of tension and the very gritty
tone of that between the top ciders and
the the you know lower class people
as well as
how
uh cataclysmic perhaps a magical event
could be yeah you know it's like you get
at least those two senses
i really love vander the whoever voices
him and like that whole character of
it's one of those things where you could
feel just such a history with this guy
and the past he used to have and all
those speeches where he like um is
he essentially like laments how
why he can't
go through with fighting for this and
you can see that he's losing the respect
of the people who all look up to him and
he he's not inspiring them in his
direction they even the kids want to
fight back even the kids want to go in
there and get their hands dirty and
violent
and
he's just so he's not even torn by it
like he has his decision made and he's
just trying to protect people he's
trying to keep people safe like you can
feel the sense that he's lost so he's
lost so many people and he's lost so
much in life that he doesn't want to
lose anymore now that he has some type
of foundation here
um and even that cop who's like who
seemed like an aggressive like annoying
henchman cop in the first episode even
he's become a lot more interesting to me
because knowing this show i'm starting
to think
what's his deal why does he hate them so
much what personal thing happened to him
what's the chip on his shoulder yeah
this is so personal for him
he really hates these people oh yeah
yeah he seems to have the utmost disdain
like i got i he either came from there
or had some very terrible experience
parents was killed yeah yeah he got
batman by somebody from the bottom side
i just love how when you cut to the
upper class people how glossy and
the what the patriarch the hierarchy all
you could you the this even like their
court is just so theatrical you know
yeah it's so ornate and striking oh yeah
dramatic yeah
yeah and then down under it you feel
like you got two very different the
worlds feel so in conflict with each
other yeah and uh
what i love about the way they flesh out
the worlds here is that the ideologies
on both ends
you just feel like they're resonating in
the air at all times yeah you don't need
to hear characters talk you can
instantly whenever you cut to the
underworld or the upper class you just
got a different you just know
what it's like and you have a cloud of
attitude yeah change yeah
and that's one of my favorite things
flushed out and then you keep cutting to
this villain who i want to get a better
sense of because he right now he seems
kind of like
disney villain to me to the point where
i'm like i need to know a little bit
more because he has guys a little cool
speech i love how even that comes in
where just you think that fight in the
first one where the kids they're
fighting to keep their backpack how that
just seems like
a fun fight yeah and then oh crap it's
led to something very important yeah
yeah i like when when anything will do
that where yeah you you think you're
just watching some sort of fun uh
adventure thing to set up who the
characters are just to get a few you
know beats out and it does that but it
also has been the catalyst for
everything it's been the domino that
sent a whole bunch of different chains
of dominoes falling over and i love how
the hunt for the kids has become very
important for the enforcers because
they know that there's some dealings
with very dangerous experimental magic
stuff and that line that the the
sympathetic cop has and i know that
actress's face
i i like her voice
you know what she's actually in x-men
the last stance she's done way more but
she's the best x-men which she's next on
the last stand when the guy from the
asian guy from saw yes
hugs the scientist lady and then lets
his spikes go off and kills her it's
that actress i think i think that's her
it's out it sounds just like i can see
her face yeah
yeah she's got such a distinct hole yeah
she said other stuff but that's the
first one i've thought of
um but like her character in particular
i forgot so caught up in trying to make
sure i'm communicating the next fencing
i remember what i was talking about what
was i saying about her i mean prior we
had been talking about her partner
before and then and then seeing like
just how much all the attitude permeates
everything and the conflict between the
two sides and all that and uh i mean she
had such a presence she always brings
such a presence but you can tell she's
trying to keep that peace and it and we
were
trying to suss out what exactly
you know the foundations of her
arrangement with van der r
yeah i haven't made that really clear it
just seems like they they fight for
peace
essentially
um
but i love the kids i love it all i love
the oh yes
how they're hunting for the the children
and and not knowing
it makes sense why there's
why they're so um
adamant about making sure they find the
children because
they don't know what they might have on
their hands right now
they like they could be some dangerous
ass matching [ __ ] in which they do
yeah they have the match yeah
uh whatever those like cube crystal
things are
and it is cool how they dealt with the
core memory of our uh j sky seeing how
his mom was saved with magic of just uh
just this random situation that
incurred and why he believed so much in
this it's not just some guy who like
read about legend
he's had personal experience that warped
his entire existence
and now he's here so while this one was
more patient i was still very much wowed
by it and the world building and you
could still feel that percolating build
of like there's something that you could
tell a collapse is on its way yeah so
yeah yeah there's a powder cake that's
about to blow up yeah i love it i love
it i love it this is a really great show
it's cool because the first episode as
exciting and fun as it is this was the
one where i'm like okay i've adjusted to
the animation um it's i'm a little bit
past because after a while you're like
yeah awesome animation is awesome
animation and but you need to also like
you know like okay what's the story
really feeling like yeah and the story
here just got better for me on all
accounts because yeah i love like the
tug of war of politics on all angles
like how does everyone in the council
feel about the magic uh how does how do
the people who vander is leading how do
they feel about going to war with the
enforcers how do the enforcers feel and
then you got this one guy off in like
his own little atlantis world
of what's going on here and i feel like
that's gonna be the main linchpin to
everything at some point right yeah
that's gonna hurt a lot of things
forward probably both magically and
civilly yes yeah so we'll see how this
progresses and then act two comes out on
saturday but we've got one more back
want to finish so guys subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button and last but not least let's do
it
everett pixelmite baker pixelmite dude
your your moniker there sounds like the
perfect code name for someone who would
live in a world like this pixel might
you might not be the biggest of stature
but you do bring the might when you're
pulling a job when you're invading
topside authorities maybe you've got to
rap i can't
you know it's about drop me a beat and
we'll see what happens but really
everett i mean dude you could lead a
revolution if you just put your mind to
it you know you gotta you don't even
need any secret serums or anything to
you know bulk your body up all you need
is some spirit and maybe a little magic
to pull it all together you know you got
to be able to flirt with danger but
harness it to lead to your ultimate
desired outcome and hey
you know the people who lead they're not
necessarily born the strongest or the
smartest or the fattest or whatever
they're the ones who are willing to do
whatever it takes i think that's you
everett so uh
especially part of what it takes is
keeping your pledge here so do that and
uh we'll see you for the revolution
buddy
he didn't wrap to my beat i
oh wait right started again
yo
[Music]